hello everyones today we are going to be
talking about heat capacity also known
as thermal capacity now this is just the
amount of heat required to change the
temperature of a material so given this
definition what units would you expect
heat capacity to have
heat is a form of energy and we're
describing how much of that is needed to
change the temperature so the units for
heat capacity are energy per temperature
and as i this would be joules per kelvin
now remember in si we use kelvin for
temperature which is the same in
magnitude as celsius so a difference of
one degree celsius is equal to a
difference of one kelvin however kelvin
does not have any negative numbers and
so zero kelvin is as low as you can get
now you probably already have an
intuitive understanding of heat capacity
even if you haven't heard it phrased
exactly like this before
imagine you have two pots of water over
the same burner but one of the pots is
full of water and the other is only
about half full
you would probably expect the one with
less water in it to boil faster
and this is actually because of heat
capacity the pot with the less water in
it has a lower heat capacity and this is
because one of the things that heat
capacity depends on is the mass of the
object or system
less water is less mass is a lower heat
capacity the other thing that the heat
capacity depends on is the material this
is also something you are probably
already intuitively familiar with
imagine you go to a barbecue on a hot
day and there are two folding chairs
left open for you to choose between one
is made of metal the other of plastic
and they've both been sitting out in the
sun you'd probably choose the plastic
one to save yourself some discomfort the
reason that the metal chair would be
hotter despite both chairs having been
sitting out in the sun is because metal
and plastic are different materials and
have different heat capacities so we
know that the heat capacity of an object
or system depends on both the mass and
the material it is made of we can
actually combine these then into
something called specific heat capacity
now the specific heat capacity is just
the heat capacity per mass
this means that the specific heat
capacity is independent of the mass of
the system because we're measuring it
per mass
therefore this is constant for a given
material this means it will take the
same amount of energy to raise the
temperature of one kilogram of any given
material but then for a different
material it will take a different amount
of energy given this what do you expect
the units of specific heat capacity to
be
well just like heat capacity we have an
energy per temperature but now we also
have a per mass in si this is going to
be joules per kelvin per kilogram this
means that the heat capacity and the
specific heat capacity are related by
mass
so
if you have a specific heat capacity
and you want to get the total heat
capacity for the object or system
then you need to multiply by the object
or system's mass
conversely if you have the heat capacity
and the mass and you want to figure out
what the specific heat capacity of a
material is you can divide the heat
capacity by the mass
however because specific heat capacity
is a constant property of a given
material we can usually just go ahead
and look up what that value is because
scientists have already measured the
specific heat capacities of lots of
materials
let's consider the water in those pots
we talked about pure liquid water has a
specific heat capacity of 4184
joules per kelvin per kilogram but
different materials have different
specific heat capacities so let's think
back to our chairs at a barbecue example
and how the metal chair is hotter than
the plastic chair now metal foaming
chairs are typically made of aluminum
which has a specific heat capacity of
897
joules per kelvin per kilogram
solid plastic however has a specific
capacity of 1
670 joules per kelvin per kilogram
so you can see from the specific heat
capacities that since the sun is
providing the same amount of energy to
both chairs the temperature of the metal
chair is getting much more increased
because it needs less energy to increase
its temperature because it has a lower
specific heat capacity
now that we see how the material changes
the heat capacity let's talk a bit more
about the mass and go back to our
example of the pots so in these pots we
have pure liquid water which we know now
has a specific heat capacity of
4184 joules per kelvin per kilogram now
the pots themselves also have a heat
capacity but we're going to ignore that
to simplify the problem if this pot has
two kilograms of water in it we can
calculate how much energy it will take
to change the temperature of this water
let's say that the initial temperature
of the water is about 300 kelvin which
is approximately room temperature and
suppose we want to use this water to
make some white tea which is made best
with water that's at about 355 kelvin
based off our understanding of heat
capacity now we can figure out how many
joules it is going to take to raise the
water from 300 kelvin to 355 kelvin
we have a specific heat capacity and a
mass and we know we can multiply those
to get a total heat capacity and we know
that by definition heat capacity is the
energy required for temperature which
means that if we multiply the heat
capacity by the change in temperature
we'll find out what the energy required
is
in fact this relationship is an
important thermodynamic equation
lower case c is commonly used for a
specific heat capacity and q for heat so
this says exactly what we've just worked
out the heat or energy required equals
the specific heat capacity times the
mass times the change in temperature
let's go ahead and put our values in
here the mass
specific heat capacity
and the change in temperature
as always we can use our units to guide
us specific heat capacity has a unit of
joules per kelvin per kilogram we're
multiplying by mass that has a unit of
kilograms so those kilograms will cancel
out we're also multiplying by a change
in temperature which is measured in
kelvin and so that will also cancel out
leaving us just with joules which isn't
energy just like we want in this case if
we multiply this together we would find
that the energy required would be 460.24
kilojoules
now let's consider the other pot if this
pot has one kilogram of water how would
that change our calculation pause the
video and think about what its heat
capacity would be
so because we still have the same
material and therefore the same specific
heat capacity the total heat capacity is
going to decrease by half because the
mass is half
and since we still want to raise the
water's temperature the same amount this
means that the energy required is going
to decrease by half as well
now requiring 230 230.12 kilojoules
so now we can see how the mass as well
as the material affect the heat capacity
today we talked about heat capacity we
learned that it is the amount of heat
required to change the temperature of a
material and that it is measured in
joules per kelvin and that it depends on
both the mass of the system and the
material that the system is made up we
did a couple of examples to help us
quantify this intuitive understanding we
have of the world around us
and i encourage you to think about the
ways heat capacity pops up in your
everyday life
for example why are some things drier
than other things when you unload the
dishwasher have a think about that
thank you so much for joining us i hope
you learned a little bit of something
and we'll see you again next time bye